I have mixed feelings about shorts.
On the one hand, lots of individual shorts are
insightful and funny and even awe-inspiring.
And let's be real, long-form videos on YouTube can often be
bloated and shorts are necessarily to the point, so I get the appeal.
At the same time, no one I know seems to actually feel good
after a long session on shorts, or reels or TikTok or whatever.
Something about the rapid barrage of instant gratification
and context switching seems to leave us feeling mentally numb.
Recently, I've been posting a pile of shorts that
are all adapted snippets from pre-existing videos.
And it's not just that this is the easiest way to get into the shorts feed,
readily outsourceable while I stay focused on new long-form lessons.
The second ulterior motive is to offer an escape hatch.
A good short is one that's thought-provoking on its own,
but unless there's a way to more deeply engage with whatever that thought is,
it feels hollow.
Since we can so nicely link to other videos right at the bottom of a short,
I kind of love the idea that anyone who wants to hop out of the
feed and engage more deeply is just one click away.